okay so everyone thinks that I have six
toes and it's really wild Kim Kardashian
proves once and for all that she's just
a gal with regular normal ordinary
feet yeah this is happening I swear fans
have been convinced for a while now that
the reality star has more than five toes
on one of her feet after several pics
surface that I'm not going to lie to you
looks like she has six toes it's so
crazy and after singer Monica recently
posted this pick with Kim and laa
Anthony fans were quick to point out
that rumored additional appendage in the
comments but now the sixth toe debate is
finally over the 39-year-old skims
designer hit up her insta story on
Wednesday to set the record straight
okay so everyone thinks that I have six
toes and it's really
wild 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 people she also
explained why it sometimes look looks
like she has an extra toe it's this part
of my foot that when I wear a shoe just
like this it like smashes down right
here and it like in a picture I don't
know why that looks like a sixth toe and
if you listen closely it sounds like
Kim's sisters Courtney and Chloe are in
the background totally trolling her okay
so
what I hope that answered my six toe
question because oh yeah only have five
toes on each foot ear to ear to
ear and not from head to toe six toes
there you have it Case Closed pack it up
Myster Sol I'm doing totally fine oddly
enough this isn't the first time a
Kardashian Jenner has had to defend
their feet I don't know how you're going
to top that okay so everyone wants to
come for mying toes by the way cute ass
feet in March Kylie Jenner clapped back
at the haters who talked mad smack about
her toes after she shared these sexy
bikini pics with her sister Kendall on
Instagram yeah fans zeroed in on her
middle toe on her right foot that
appears to be shorter than the rest of
them I broke this middle toe in middle
school and you can't really there's
nothing you do for a broken toe so I
just had to let it heal how it wanted to
heal so when I flex this up wait when I
like Flex it it's all this is a weird
ass video honestly she took the words
right out of my mouth weird ass video
you could see it better when I'm
standing so when I flex this up they're
all normal and like in place the middle
toe focus on the middle toe and then
when I flex this
up this little guy just like is out of
[Music]
place